they can do so much with it so ear you
mentioned buying a cup of coffee great
let's talk about that right now the
acceptability for Bitcoin is incredible
you have MasterCard
Visa creating intermediary payment rails
which actually allow you to top up your
card and then spend your Bitcoin I can't
go buy I can't buy I can't take this off
and get a cup of coffee with it you
wouldn't buy a cup of coffee with your
gold bracelet but I can't buy Bitcoin
but you can also have a token back by
gold and use that to buy your coffee and
you can always do it a to a token where
there's well there's centralized
exchange be which can be frozen if I
don't have the correct political opinion